renowned academic Noam Chomsky told the
Wall Street Journal that his meetings
with Jeffrey Epstein are quote none of
your business none of your business The
Wall Street Journal reports that Chomsky
held multiple meetings with Jeffrey
Epstein chomsky's meetings with Epstein
took place long after the disgraced
financier had registered as a sex
offender so the idea of this was long
before anybody knew anything not valid
it was it was known Chomsky said and
this one is a little weird if there was
a flight which I doubt it would have
been from Boston to New York 30 minutes
see I would remember whether I flew with
Jeffrey Epstein that I that's strange so
listen I agree that the responses are a
little bit odd I also have no reason
whatsoever to believe that Chomsky did
anything inappropriate as it relates to
the things that Epstein was accused and
previously convicted of